hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from last year's a
Russian team championship it's Sega
dubofsky vs kiddo Alex & Co and as
everyone is discussing who should get
the final spot in the candidates
tournaments to be the wild card whether
it should be relaxing who qualified via
the feeder grin Swiss or max impartial a
graph who is almost qualified via any
any other means we we're gonna check out
this game first and then I have I
prepared for you an open letter to the
Russian Chess Federation from MBL's
manager so we're gonna discuss that a
bit more but before that here's one of
the nicer games I found since we didn't
cover all that many games but like senko
at the see what he can do here it's a
really exciting game Rublev ski is a
pure attacker and he really goes for
Alex & Co and well you just have to see
what happens so Wroblewski opens with E
4 we have C 5 by Alex & Co now he goes
for the Sicilian defense we have Knight
to f3 d6 and d4 captures captures with
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and a6 denied
of defense and it's interesting
both the Rublev ski and Alex & Co are
fond of the nigel defense we have a
Bishop to e2 5 now pushing the knight
back Knight b3 and Bishop to e7
preparing to Castle so both players just
castle and here rook to e1 the idea is
you're gonna place the Bishop player 3
the e4 pawn will be nicely protected and
that the bishop Knight Queen and pawn
will be participating in the battle for
the d5 square preventing black from
pushing d5 so Bishop to e6 just
developing gaining more control the d5
square white does the same now the d5
square is nicely covered
Knight B to d7 and a4 now preparing beef
preventing b5 we have Queen to b8 and by
Alex and Co you will at some point re
maneuver this Bishop through dh2 b6 it
will be very strong put weight will put
pressure on the f2 form but also gain
more control of the c5 square so h3
making some room for a king also taking
away the g4 square from Alex and goes
pieces and now rook the c8
we have night the D to the night is
coming to f1 from f1 he the night can
come to g3 or just control the e3 score
so you can develop the Bishop to e3 the
counter blacks the dark square Bishop
when it comes to b6 so rush of the d8
black continues with this plan we have
Knights the f1 and Bishop to b6 and here
Rudovsky
goes a5 pushes the bishop further back
Bishop to d4 and now you don't want to
play Bishop to e3 right away first you
want to improve your position as much as
possible in 92
now again you threaten the bishop bishop
back to c5 and only now Bishop to e3
that the Knights are nicely placed with
b6 now defending the bishop also putting
pressure on the e5 pawn a captures Queen
captures and now b3 so the B to pawn is
no longer a target and a 5 and here we
have a night eat the g3 now the knight
can come to f5 so Alex & Co prevents it
with the g6 and here we have Knight to
f5 and this is something that Wroblewski
prepared for this game and it's a really
really exciting move I forgot to mention
we already had a new move in the
position
this is move 20 was actually a move 16
so we're just gonna I'm not gonna move
backwards but basically four moves have
already been played since it was ok I'm
just gonna show it it was in this
position after Bishop to d4 Knight to d5
was a non move it was actually played by
Alex and Co himself against Alexis Arana
and Alexei who lost that game so here
Knight to e2 is basically the poison
that wróblewski brought to this game and
now we already saw Bishop c5 Bishop b3
b6 capture screen captures and then now
b3 taking care of the weakness a 5 and
night to G tonight EG 3 now we reach
this position where g6 was played Alex &
Co prevents Knight to a5 but Wroblewski
plays it anyway and here there is really
a position for you to enjoy you can
pause the video and try to figure out if
it's ok to capture the night while I
give you a couple of seconds or you know
take as much as you want
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations I'm figuring out that
it's most definitely not okay to capture
the night and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
well if you capture the night then he
captures opens up an attack on the
bishop and the rook and you might think
well okay two pieces for a rook are I'm
game
so Bishop captures an a5 Bishop
character Sunday 8th and the rook
captures an a8 so yes you have two
pieces for a rope the problem is the
white has Queen f3 with an attack on the
bishop and the rook but black has a
response to that as well there should be
four takes care of both threats but now
White has Bishop captures on c5
attacking blacks Queen and also
introducing another attacker to the
bishop on e4 so here whatever you do
White will just be better but basically
if you play something like Queen
captures on c5 rook captures on e4
Knight captures any for Queen captures
any for the material is completely equal
however the rook is hanging and also
there's the threat of Queen to g4 check
which picks up the night on d7 so you
have the defendable threats you move the
rook defend the night but still queen g4
check King h8 or if it doesn't even
matter in the 93 and if we look at this
position black the black king is well
wide open the night is coming to f5 it
will be very difficult for black to
defend this so this is this is the
position you get if black plays perfect
defense after accepting the knight
sacrifice which as you can see in the
material on the board now is equal after
something moves so it's not really a
sacrifice but basically with perfect
play black will be lost so you cannot
capture the night so I mean I can only
imagine Alex anko took his time to
decipher this position he played rook to
d8 he continues the fight for that for
the d5 square we have g4 now
now the knight can definitely not be
captured with with the pawn because
after well you'll just see King h8 was
played a night one at the g3 getting the
other night and now if you capture the
night you just get he captures and the
bishop is trapped so a the bishop hanks
and also you you can just go for the
rook so not really I defy will be played
in F Capra's on e6
not really gaining anything so Bishop
captures on e3 first by like Cinco
Knight captures on e3 and now Knight the
c5 so again trying to reach that d5
square but g5 removing one of the
defenders of the d5 square we have
Knight back to g8 and now Bishop to g4
and here you could trade if Bishop
captures Queen captures it's possible
however White will get a do too many
squares after the Queen moves the knight
can come here then I can come to f6 it's
not going to be a pleasant position for
black to defend so here Alex and Co
played f6 and he allowed White's to gain
complete control of the d5 square and
also win a pawn
so here wróblewski played Bishop
captures on e6 we have Knight captures
on e6 and now Knight to d5 not a very
complicated line so it's very
interesting to see what Alex Alex and Co
had in mind when he played f6 so the
Queen is under attack the battle for d5
square is over white won that battle
Queen the a7 and now G captures on f6 so
grabbing a pawn and already having a
passed pawn on f6 rook the f8 now
preparing to win back the pawn but
Wroblewski just goes rook to e3 and here
you could capture the pawn but if you
capture the pawn you get a knight
captures rook captures and Queen
captures and d6 so you lose the d6 pawn
and there are no good discoveries with
the knight so again you're just in a in
a worse position with being down upon
but it's definitely playable and it's
probably what what you could have gone
for Knight to f4 also very interesting
but Alex & Co goes for Queen to f7
and now comes Knight to e2 here white
just prepares f4 we have Knight to g5 by
Alex & Co and now Knight to b6 putting
pressure on the rook here rook a to be 8
and now f4 so what do you do here here
are all extinct o has to make a decision
and basically the decision is whether
you move the knight somewhere and allow
white to start marching those pawns
forward or do you capture the pawn or
maybe you play something else so
basically if you capture it captures on
f4 you're gonna get a knight captures an
f4
definite chapters nf6 queen deform just
opening up this diagonal and it's not
going to be pleasant for black the rook
is coming to f1 the night is coming to
d5 you're gonna pile up on the pin piece
but it was Alex and hos best best hope
here Alex & Co played Knight captures on
f6 instead he gives up the the night
here and he finds an even deadlier line
which is a well which is just very
interesting here we have F captors and
g5 and now Knight to g4 and here you
don't really you don't really have a
good reply whatever you do here it's
just it's just over for white so all of
a sudden that's that's what happens when
you when you find such an f6 line and
well there just is no good good move for
Rublev ski here wróblewski played h
captors and g4 but even if you play
something like Queen to f1 just the
Queen captures rook captures on f1 row
capture screen captures you pick up the
rope with check King has to move and now
you capture the C do pawn it's just a
completely winning endgame for black key
or your Europe upon and you rob the
exchange so here after Knight to g4
Wroblewski played h-cat % g4 but now
it's the same Queen f2 check we have
team - h1 and Queen captures on e3 so
yes now you do have to two nights for a
rook but it doesn't matter here we have
nights to see for attacking the Queen
but just well I feel free to pause the
video and try to find it it's a it's a
forced mate in in 5 so I will give you a
couple of seconds to spot it so for
those of you who were able to do it -
congratulations and finding a nice mate
in five and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
Queen to f3 is a results in mate mate in
five Alex and co-found made in six he
played Queen to h3 check which works
just as just as well
King Jiwon and now Queen characters and
g4 with check King back to h1 and here
he played rook to f2 and it was in this
position that Sergei wróblewski resigned
the game as there is no defense against
Queen to h3 fall by Queen to h2 mate
whatever you play there is a really no
point in even trying to defend this if
the Queen blocks then you even block
your own escape square for the Kings who
have to again the same mate follows swim
this is one of the games I wanted to
show you really complicated game and
like I said at the disposition when
Bishop the d4 was played Knights the d5
was a non move by Alex & Co versus
Alexis Arana and nice to e 2 followed by
this g3 idea and Knight f5 was a
prepared poisoned by Wroblewski and Alex
& Co was able to refute it and well in
the Indians win the game very nicely
after this rook to have to move so
that's the the one I found I I checked a
few games this is one I really enjoyed
this it features a really really
powerful attack and you know you Alex
anko defended and was able to win the
game and like I promised here is the
open letter from MBL's manager to the
Russian Chess Federation we're just
gonna read it so let's dive straight
into it so there we have it an open
letter to the Russian Chess Federation
it says qualification for the candidates
tournament to be held in Yekaterinburg
March to 2020 concluded yesterday in
Jerusalem congratulations to Yanni Pony
issue for winning the tournament and for
taking the 7th qualifying spot the
eighth and last Spade place will be
awarded by the organizers to a player
eligible according to feeder rules the
wild card a questionable privilege that
we hope will disappear for the next
World Championship cycle on November
11th in a press conference announcing
the Russian international chess events
of 2020 the president of the russian
Chess Federation
Andrey Filatov had stated that he was
pleased with the organization of the
candidates tournament in Yekaterinburg
because it guaranteed the presence of a
Russian player the situation has changed
since then and Sasha Gray shook and Yana
pony she both qualified via via the
feeder Grand Prix the Russian Chess
Federation could therefore choose to
give the wild-card to the only eligible
Russian player Kira alexengel
for his third place at the grand Swiss
that took place on the Isle of Man but
on a purely sporting level it could
legitimately pick Maxime for Sheila
Grove and will for short three times
eligible
and first non-qualified player by 2019
average rating 2019 World Cup in 2019
feeder Grand Prix whether it opts for a
third Russian player or for the most
obvious sporting choice the Russian
Chess Federation sir remains sovereign
in its decisions however we suggest it
takes into consideration the possibility
of organizing a mvl Alex & Co match in
order to earn the wild-card spot it
would have the merit of preserving
sporting equity and would I believe meet
the wishes of a vast majority of chess
enthusiasts throughout the world there
we have it
laurent vrat MBL's manager so there you
have it that's the open letter to the
Russian Chess Federation now what are
your thoughts on this should should they
give the World Court to Alex Inc or
should they give it to MVL who is most
likely the the the obvious choice if we
don't follow the rules or would you guys
enjoy seeing a short match let's say
maybe a four game or an eight game match
Alex & Co vs. mvl to determine who gets
the last spot in the candidates from
2020 so what are your what are your
thoughts on this I'm very interested do
share in the comments section below
you know maybe maybe maybe someone has a
really really brilliant idea then that
we can share and maybe they use that who
knows how but yeah that's the game and
the open letter to the Russian Chess
Federation I do hope you enjoyed that as
well I would like to thank Kudo chess
club for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see soon
continuing the coverage of the Sun wages
which already finished but we do have to
check up on good ol Antone horrible and
chalky checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world meaning the world with
and rapid championship so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day